let's take Karen I'll finish it if you
do what some fool podcast welcome to the
what's awful Parker with Rodrigo Torres
right here yeah man in the house
at least I will be here chillin right
here do we check out her files so
they're showing me slick we freestyle
over here we had should be the doctor
it's gonna be the prescription over here
okay we need one aspirins thank you note
from your mom with that have ready bro
chicken scratch you get a bad note for
your mom for bad handwriting for not
being on at school and then they tell
you you're machi come back your mom
should come back a finished degree they
pull out all these excuse notes from
Bart's file and they said clearly he's
like a delinquent and he's forged all of
these notes and and homers like signing
something and it's the same handwriting
as the notes but it looks like a child's
handwriting all those notes they thought
that Bart forged but it were they were
smaller and we have carried our guest
here house key that's right no activity
should a GUI podcast podcast paranormal
Karen paranormal carry em down so a
superhero sounds spooky already so how
many know you know what Bart seems to
know here yeah counterfeiting stuff or
like talking about chicken scratch
that's the history of that conversation
a few scratches we write like crap so
they go don't give me that chicken
scratch the teacher gives it back you
never heard that expression you never
heard never I do my writing was always
perfect boy yo scratch no they were that
no yeah chicken scratch how will you
carry all right
failure but I didn't know it came from
where she said oh really yeah that's a
little bit of what makes sense yeah
totally
even if you made it up right now it
makes sense I might have half made yeah
no scratch writing we would get mad do
give a scratch paper but that's it
that's probably part of universal Enix
chicken scratch yeah chicken scratch oh
you don't know how to write properly I
love people don't even use pesto in the
more the kids they don't teach cursive
in school anymore as old school has
right Isaac had two weeks of cursive
that may you are a little cursive now
you got a little prison learn a new fine
had to buy a child's book in cursive to
help him with his writing and he's over
there more that's your kid now you don't
know cursive I don't think about words
[Laughter]
yeah man what's up chillin bro you got
to do hat on yeah you like it yeah it is
bad I liked it huh would you get it dude
over there intra mosa dog oh that the
skater plays next door
yeah dude no it's actually around the
corner the et skate shop right there was
badass dude in the play that used to be
a bigger place and to be a play there
was a bar with a Doc Martens and like
yeah yeah no not that place it's like
the skate shops sure surf skating snow
what's up fool man what's up doc so
nobody knows handwriting I guess we're
gonna communicate here anyway so tonight
if you wanna watch it tonight listening
to the show watch it live I'm gonna be
at the Arsenal every live Thursday
through Sunday show one more chicken
scratch we met Paul Reiser yesterday
cool August 10 Amarillo Texas August 11
McAllen Texas August 24th Lubbock Texas
I got 25 Loretto Texas September moving
to Texas
July 19 through 20 second Oxnard every
life I guess
through the fourth Jacksonville Florida
at the Carboni stone that should be
funny I guess I'm gonna spend a lot of
terrible hotel room that that week it
was hard at all that time this is our
video feed is punch-drunk sports by the
way so people are turning in it from
punched I better just turn off sorry to
so troubling died here man what's going
on boss just tripping down oh sorry bro
why I won't buddy
the little penny for your little
Pendleton on those yeah it's a little
ass you know a little Bob's Big Boy
these guys should the guy told me that
that logo came to a show and he was shy
bro like here at the tea-table to give a
free yeah you be that shy I never eats
ever free stuff even when I got everyone
I told me you're gonna get a free
t-shirt
I will first like there's like if they
gave me one that's too big like 3x but
I'm a large back then I'll get that was
too big for me well here's a large but I
still keep it three eggs bro yeah I
wouldn't throw back anything back unless
they asked for it like like every
mistake I've had at restaurants at
Starbucks I'm eating their mistakes I
[ __ ] up your drink let me give you a
venti get bring any there's also a
company there's also a cappuccino here
that somebody left behind you want that
too I'll take it
who go back to work with seven free
drinks kept the money for my employees
teaching you and I'm thinking you're not
gonna give that a anything they give it
to me
the good throw it away anyways do it's
waste can I have those that's how you
always ask what did that did like what
would you make you one sample king I am
sample we're at Starbucks yesterday and
they had like our two but two days ago
they had like this tap for all their
nitrogen ice thank you they had natural
child to nitro everything really
avocation like peach tea you know this
sleepers like he just pulled a seat up
to the bar like bigger you know samples
and say you think so and then I gather
the charger that will stay right next to
me over those days I thought I get
louder don't look good
get a little fancy mustache grow
delicious oh you won't eat that can i
and they were astir no more but I'll say
yes and let them answer for me yeah he
sees it in eyes would you like free I'm
free of orange chicken can i yes you
could okay bring it whatever took Isaac
row to get up samples this fool ate all
the sampling it in base sample he kept
going dude I didn't ought to do samples
like you can't go you know the sample
every time you change teachers what's up
fool
paranormal Rodrigo right here who's
laughing you watching this Matt don't do
this to people anymore
let me go greet people like that unless
you're as big as a person actually know
it might hurt hey they could touch my
non-fat boards now they don't like touch
with North Park bro
these are like what a hug or squeeze a
little fat did was because I'll fight a
little faster under the armpit under the
ribcage behind the knee but so Ambler
they have a lot of fat if you ski the
big show they get mad oh did it get
pierced and if you're having sex behind
overly you squeeze the stomach started
push you up and down I'm a grabber
I know they start squeezing and I you're
making dough here making Kobe beef
I don't like Jen touch after sex neither
I don't
I don't like cutting all dirty a helmet
I want you to go the bathroom get a warm
rag this [ __ ] uppers a warm rag you
can't use my shower
I nobody you know relax get all clean
you know dude I don't wanna be looking
to have eyelash you know no I your
eyelash came out three sex lookit I
wanna oh you know you ever seen a half I
eyebrow and eyelash right now
and it wasn't a wicked I mean so never
believe anything you say detective well
you're putting somebody's hair their
wigs hose off a lot of chicks were
extension to huh with that thing that's
here oh you put your finger inside with
you know this tension and get stuck you
pull up blood pull up the scalpel
scalpel person who are into paranormal
probe but they're like two into another
freak you out and not me not anybody
Renee I've had I've had a couple
encounter tell your stories but yeah we
had a paranormal activity encounter
never me when I was like 10 or 12 years
old I was living in the housing projects
of course I grew up that there and we
had any man and we are just know so what
happened to projects dog first I bought
a baseball somewhere I cannot weirdo
addicts I'm for a baseball and at one
time I was just laying my mouth bed but
on one of those beds you know you know
like if you have four bedrooms but if
you have your door open and the other
person in the other room has a door open
you can see inside the room and yeah you
gotta close it or the other TV on you
can see their TV and you must be who I
thought old lady passed by and wearing a
sock or bro like her she probably didn't
yeah like a housecoat and she just
passed by and then I think she look
look when she kept walking then I met
the lesbian sister used to live I know I
mean that ghost yeah they were there
were friends no they were friends
because they had a they had a do that
was very very slow and he had those are
forrest gump metal legs so he was tin
man bro so he worked like a puppet and
he Chuck's know but just Fuuka back hard
to bro the best this dude got a good
word time somebody said something you
know they'd have food just doing the
perfect timing
look here's more I was almost took it my
toes off and laying beat him with him
but it was funny do cuz Teddy had to
hear these two cousins and whenever I
was chubby and she always wore a leave I
thought he'd leave my jacket the one
with fur they were into rock and roll
and I'm the other girl look like like
Lou Diamond Phillips if he was a woman
and he was neat
she dressed with her bald lesbian so we
hung out with them but but they never
played with us but they held on the
behind us like were part of the group or
not part of the group of daughters
smoking weed behind us kept an eye on
you yeah man so I met them I started
talking to them and I told her where I
live - oh [ __ ] my grandma used to live
there she died in him some room there
you go and I said now I tell him I
[ __ ] saw the grandma broke up I don't
wanna have had a long conversation about
I don't wanna see the grandma again well
was she wearing should wear Levi's
jacket wear metal legs you tell your mom
about this hell yeah I screamed though
she also do you did things to see
something what'd she say nothing brother
what's good god I yeah I've never seen
anything I wanted to see something -
some dude named Aaron Blair's house
supposedly was haunted but not the Arab
No decided to see anything and
supposedly my lady's house is haunted
where her parents live just kind of like
you sneak away to this go to the
restroom at night so just run in the
restroom quick use it and run back and
then one time I didn't I thought I seen
something it was her dad hey buddy use
the restroom also another Mexico my dad
or my uncle will tell us scare you like
if you don't put your you know put black
it's also with her grab your feet yeah
and then like something about also
another one was not the chupacabra right
but those chupacabras when I was a kid
but they were not our baby goats oh they
don't they eat the goat
what ever seen them I just I heard that
somebody was killing goats but also that
if you don't kill a frog or whatever I
don't know happen but I told a coach
okay at night too
yeah and then now when I was down in
Texas somebody told me that Oh gravity
Hill
oh yeah yeah yeah well here right here
hear it now by Dodger Stadium Eagle Rock
no but dr. stadium Alicia Park there's a
there's a mountain right there like I
hear a my friend and I were I won't say
we were still cars but I wasn't alive
stolen vehicles and I wasn't once called
a vehicle cuz I get where it goes so bad
so he just thinks took somebody's car
Brody I don't know how he got it but he
gave me a ride and had a Kenwood had
everything then you go watch it boys
gravity heal so he put the car like this
like you know right like it's gonna go
up the hill and then of the car you put
out neutral and he goes think Wyatt
watch stay quiet stay quiet and then the
car didn't go roll down roll a roll back
up
oh that's weird that's actually a
science thing though
what's that even know yeah but we call
the gravity humans discounting reality
yeah they're freaked me out bro I like
that flipped out dog because we're a
Dodger Stadium write songs they give
that up
my friend was telling me lies and
everybody Rhonda was saying oh man
everybody that was like barely alive or
through each other ravine the rail right
here they're trying to come out so they
push everything out and then in Texas
this girl Tori was that um they were in
like a I'm a real Oh
but we said oh I'm gonna be there in
Amarillo by the way Lubbock those are
scooped it was like they put like this
car by the train tracks and it put white
flour over it baby powder baby powder
and then uh they waited they waited and
I don't know what happened they went
back there's a lot of like kids
fingerprints like palm prints all over
the car it's a legend that the kids were
on a school bus that got hit and got
killed there so they wait there and if
you leave your car there too long they
will push your car if your car's a
neutral they'll push it out of dangers
they're trying to help
oh push it out what's out I dreamt that
my grandma showed up to my bedroom and I
freaked me I thought I crying I had
dreams I woke up crying though like in
tears but I never said goodbye to her
that she was I felt like you know in my
own mind saying maybe she shows telling
me goodbye but she showed up in my dream
like a normal person healthy you know
stolen in her 80s sitting down we're
wearing her [ __ ] go big old gold
chain how you remember her I remember
her broke old rings looking like a Mayan
goddess bro in modern day times you know
was you know just a bunch of gold
medallions hair straight green eyes I've
had dreams like that with past relatives
but she showed up is it a ssin really
yeah yeah yeah paranormal oh yeah yeah
paranormal just means not norm
so yeah but they always look kind of
like their 30-ish opposed to Hollywood
where you're supposed to look 18
everybody kind of looks healthy and
30-ish like their best years of their
lives that's very common yeah Wow
visitation
I guess I'm part of the club now yeah
unfortunately but I've had dreams of
people who were passed away they're
alive in the dream
yeah do you like vit like like I'm
looking at him like me and you having a
conversation right now it's trippy dude
and they say stuff that like do you like
continued on from now where you left off
with how it would have been if they
would be here but the memory of them in
your dream is always there they never
died I know it's just like me you right
now dude and then like you wake up and
like you're gonna take a shower and you
know go to work away how to clearly be
one time I know what that meant but oh
dude I was I was out drugged out I was
out doing a lot of drugs back then and
going days at a time without sleeping I
met this chick brought the beach hot
right
beyond out of my league just Lisa right
yeah oh yeah and we had like a log date
in my dream it for like hours is what
would you wake up bro and you want to
die go back I know huh like you wanna go
back my wrist my real life over there
but then I walk I walk it was perfect
bro a long date but nevertheless I'm
gonna get back to the street but I
realized why I'm all my dreams were
great back then because I'm dictating
other lines I'm saying in my mind
they're saying what I wanted to say you
know they're their thoughts are my
thoughts you know when you think about
person you know when you think about
someone you miss and they're talking to
you they're talking to you in your words
not their words cuz in their worries get
me off your thoughts [ __ ] don't
forget to get about me you piece of [ __ ]
it's over for a reason but I said I woke
up and wanted to go back right but did
it go back so a week later to it later I
dreamt about her again
and she's told me my dream where were
you at I missed you last week dan
welcome screaming like a dog
we're back to do a lot of colegrove's to
the way for five days freak out that has
nothing to do with lack of sleep maybe
no but it has a I have a theory with it
go for you if you were doing a lot of
drugs she was asking you to get back to
you to who you were ambu from goes down
does you Italia me just a dream no sound
scary though now I'm doing dreamer nails
yeah she was it she wanted you to go
back to beautiful you oh that's too
heavy we know have to conclude and
what's up with that how'd you get into
it what's going on
paranormal I've always had two
experiences since I was a little kid and
I was always into psychic stuff and the
I was not a doll girl but even to this
day I have a witch doll that I got when
I was a little kid it was the only doll
I ever liked it's horrible like people
hate it literally took it with me
everywhere lost it on a move from Las
Vegas to San Diego and then like five
years later my mom goes we're leaving
we're selling our house we found this in
the Attic do you want it and it was the
doll I have no idea how it got to
Massachusetts but it just showed up and
I was like well that sounds like my life
Annabelle yeah that's a bad doll I know
the guy that owns that doll no because
you meet people who have some strange
objects right objects experience yeah
everything people do somebody just call
me the other day and she was like I've
got the evil eye what do i do what do I
do
Indianapolis back to Indianapolis
get it back up we're stuck
yeah I know what you're referring ya
know I've heard it all better to walk
tenderly cuz I know you guys are not I
don't want anyone go home and have
nightmares was that cool yeah no I had
experiences psychic experiences and I've
seen very rare to see a full-body
apparition but I saw one ironically I
left not when I was investigating just
standing over my bed just a guy in jeans
standing over my bed watching me sleep
we have comedian Mehmood or nighttime
paranormal people but they say it was
preordained oh yeah is it fate or you
bet your dog in oh yeah what's her name
say you got your darling you little then
you found it again yeah it's me
everywhere and when I moved to San Diego
from Las Vegas to San Diego it got lost
in the move no more doll big frog took
it big frog bullfrog
that's right bullfrog took it and
carried it back to Massachusetts and
then my parents found it in their attic
somehow it like reappeared in
Massachusetts only though I'm not a doll
I was laughing about to get what I just
walk to a desert you know what's
tripping me a food now you have a little
dog dog what dog the little dog I made
for me no that was the only doll I
wasn't a doll person I wasn't a princess
person were you a princess girl
I was kind of calm boyish but some I
also did have some like Barbies like
baby dolls but I like I like dressing up
and acting the new Barbies I had new
Barbies I had all the International
Barbies they had a line of international
bar I was really into Mexican Barbie
Barbie co-op but yeah I didn't like baby
dolls I didn't I didn't want to be a
baby here you know like yeah people go
off for that American though right oh
yeah freak as hell they have like tea
parties and stuff it's almost they have
health care
my dad one time he may not have a tea
party with my sister with a WAC just to
play with her though why she was only
girl though yeah accent a tea party bro
we never really had never really had
real tea parties brother like hope my
dad holding one finger like this
yeah real bread line my brother were 14
assigning each other killed my dad but
that was trying to do my sister's hair
[ __ ] Oh bro oh my god
little is waggy so so so back to the
stuff so paranormal things always happen
to you as a kid yeah oh the dot was a
doll reappeared like a couple years ago
no I mean that after you got the doll
sorry oh no always Oh even before always
I had a head experience where my sister
was we were swimming in the ocean and my
sister had epilepsy and she was about 20
feet away from me and she looked at me
and she screamed helped me I'm gonna
have a seizure and I ran out and she was
right next to my father and she put her
arms around my neck and I started to run
into Shore and then a voice I heard said
no go the other way
so I started running deeper into the
water and then my father said the only
thing that made it over the curl was her
head and if we had been in earlier she
would have tumbled and then when we got
to shore I said to my dad why didn't you
grab her when she screamed and he says
she never screamed and she said I never
screamed so apparently I was the only
one that hurt her I continued to have a
seizure yes so the seizure ah it was
probably the first that I remember but
then all my life's been pretty creepy
fun how about you Barbara I don't know
if you ever had any paranormal
experiences just remember man why now
just remember
they were spaced joke time-life books i
had cured a shot a woman to the sharp
pain in her in her head harm what she's
doing dishes at the same time all the
way her daughter's keeping her boyfriend
[Laughter]
type life boys have paranormal you're a
kid yeah 2,000 miles away her daughter's
about to get on a plane and decides not
coincidence time-life books paranormal
stories are the unknown but but Davis
Bay had a joke about it there with
[ __ ] hilarious comedy a woman feel
the sharp pain while doing dishes to
thought them out of the way
her daughter's giving her boyfriend Ron
I had given up a run
but would you rich we're both kids when
you saw those books when I saw a book
that was what I say of course a lot of
stuff I wanted but those books I wanted
oh yeah [ __ ] the encyclopedias bro I
wanted I know the a lot of volumes -
yeah I think there's still you know we I
I didn't they wouldn't buy me those but
I have them now even people felt stuff
right in their self-conscious it goes
all the way back to the beginning of
time it goes oh I was just doing one on
they call them gin I'm doing my episode
on gin that's like a middle-eastern
demon kind of and it goes all the way
back to the Bible they're mentioning in
the Bible so it's it's been forever that
people have always believed in something
you know Lucas oh yeah yeah he reads a
tea leaves yes yeah no we did we had him
on our show coming here it can read
where we did a reading for him and then
he said he was gonna read him but we
never got around to me you read yeah he
may like he went to the kitchen and he
got like the little turkey boy here like
this he brewed coffee in the kitchen and
a panel okay a little coffee thing he
burned the coffee grinder Turkish coffee
Turkish
coffee and imported it was take your
time I drank it and then he just flipped
it over I think he deleted to this the
dish after reading it I read my future
it's good thing you had that experience
with the tea party when you were younger
why did he have a good future for you
yes then I remember all dead in Columbus
Ohio we did a comedy show we were hung
out with a bunch of Navy people and
there was these two Navy girls and one
of the neighbor girl that was the
dominican lady she was like she was
they're both high rank that's why they
got to hang out everybody else left and
she read my she read out my palm in
another comedians palm and I my palm she
told me stuff that I might even tell her
I had a daughter I didn't tell me I had
a daughter
ten grandkids but she knew like that um
she was you have a daughter she loves
you she's going through a lot of hard
times right now bah blah and then when I
met my daughter later later on we talked
and it won't she'd see that she was Wow
so you were a believer well I believed I
didn't believe it then but when I
remember my dad my daughter I said
something that yeah it's just how did
she know that she opened my listing oh
my wallet did she talk to the other
comedians for what's up with the palm
Carrie I'm not a problem but there's a
there's two ways they do that one is
reading the lines like certain lines
mean certain things
yeah and others is like Keira when she
reached on our other podcast Karen Keira
can read she just is sort of pulling
energy just kind of reading that I read
stretch marks you are 400 pounds
yeah I had my palm read one time by a
friend but she had done it for years I
guess and I guess this is my love line
and she said you'll have a really long
marriage and then
the first marriage my second ready get
your bags packed but no she said and she
said here's where it splits off and then
there's another relationship that starts
after that I said there's no way where's
that loved one only have one it's either
I think it's the same although this
one's more lit than this one Wow so wait
this one would be yours but yours kind
of ends right there
mine goes to the end is it I have none
bro mine fades like yours I'm like goes
for a long time and then that when young
girls asked me something I'm like you're
gonna have two marriages and they're
like what and I'm like oh come on you're
too young you're gonna be sick of the
first person to is good I knew another
female comic is used to come to the wild
coyotes before I booked it it was booked
by Gotham's and she did numbers Oh
numerology I do
oh that's okay and like if we're good
our audience was like Latino they are
working you know blue-collar Latinos
Catholics Catholics basically they were
tripping out man
she'll call this guy Gordy but I saw and
then I saw her twice there and then I
saw her on a big side of a show
Jenny Joel the Jerry Springer one of the
big shows doing that oh you know what I
bet it was her name was Glynnis didn't
she tall blonde woman no maybe I'm wrong
then maybe there's a couple numerology
is pretty good pretty easy what did we
do
what is the month the day in month of
your birthday that you
June 11 at 7-eleven okay so that's eight
nine ten okay so you're in a year one
numerologically which means this year is
all about beginnings for you beginning
beginning beginning last year you
probably saw a lot of things leaving
your life that you didn't need this year
all getting ready to set up for the next
nine years so you're in a one
everything's independent everything's
independent yeah yeah what about you
January 12 so that's one two so that's
four five six who your year is all about
love we were gonna just do it like just
quick civil and then have a little party
because it's like you know a lot of
stuff's going on we're gonna get it over
with you and like you know whatever but
not it's not us it's not a set date if
you make it through this year it's good
Lisa
birthday February 16 to 60 in three and
six is nine one two you're in a year way
February right you're in a year to which
your year is all about partnerships one
on one not groups okay so at all one of
the organization ships partnership right
yes wow dude that's trippy man
numerology is funny we know bro oh my
god and your comic too though yeah
that's where I make in San Diego
actually I started in Vegas a little bit
but there was nothing there I was a
cigarette girl at Caesars and I met a
bellman and he took me to do it and I
was just that's right everybody's gonna
love you yeah and I was terrible and I
was like that's what I'm doing the rest
of my life gotten I got one laugh on a
dirty joke and then everything I wrote
just was horrible it was
I had little ripped up napkin in my hand
and I'd say what was how can you tell
what someone's been I can't remember but
the punch line is that you COFF and it
blows out and the question the thing was
like you were blowing a chicken house
somebody's giving a ticket of blow
drivers that you and little feathers go
out and it was just the bar everybody
died but then I moved to San Diego
Comedy Store that's where I started
oh yeah yeah so there's great yeah
they'd have a little foosball or
something like a pool table air hockey a
bumper pool maybe that's new yeah I
haven't been there in a while
old lady old lady back in my day that
was in the 80s so that was kind of it
started you know frame example I know
FEMA's not very well told women were
fighting over me one said you saw him
first
no you saw him he's calm oh yeah fight
was another joke go to every door he
goes I heard Olympic skater Picabo
Street might go into medicine I let you
hear that at the hospital peekaboo ICU
[Laughter]
yeah he will work he will live it was a
guy named Fred Fred burns Fred started
my career yeah Fred passed away Frank
still around yeah Freddy was to work
crutches mm-hmm they were living
together and the last time I saw Frank
Manzano I would live in an audition and
I was heading back to Glendale well used
to live and he was catching a bus we
both looked at each other he was a blue
and how you build meribella blah he goes
I got a stop with comedy right after
Fred died I mean know where Fred died
but do you ever seen Fred never Birds oh
my god did you stop you know people say
the Reggie right other [ __ ] there's
the [ __ ] I went over the envelope
fred was live there yeah he was at
school I guess everybody had spina
bifida so his customer would dog yeah he
was supposed to pass away when he was
like 18 and he died at like 55 and he
died of emphysema of all things he lived
like this is gonna kill me
and he died from smoking yeah it was
dirty dude got this horrible Eric
Clapton joke bro he'll be like he'll be
a Hilton he'll put his back to the crowd
and then like he'll had like one of the
color people are working with you in the
audience plant a plant you know Eric
how's your kid how's your baby and he'll
turn around and you're a long straw
Latinos to make a thing that he was
doing coke with baby fall of the wall
yeah fregley
fred lived to offend but he was really
funny too funny i stopped before money
twice oh man yeah but Frank's don't
prank shows up every time I have to move
I don't know like he senses that he's
like how you moving and he pulls up with
the truck and I'm like all right man
that's great yeah that's a good friend I
work with Frank Misano me and another
comedian and we told you - yeah we're
gonna make this guy work but um you know
it's not much of a professional he was
we're not used to performing for 20
people so we rented a gas at 10 minute
at by minutes but we had nothing left
this guy went up there bro took his time
and but time you got offstage there was
25 people but it was like a la jolla on
a Tuesday you know yeah yeah yeah when I
did when I stepped in that's when they
first started papering rooms like like a
right from the beginning I had a room
seven nights ago work out you
the Hirai yeah that was the beginning of
the big 80s boom West papering and
teammates yeah yeah yeah but it was a
great way to learn man every night full
room just trying new stuff on a full
room every night it was amazing yeah Wow
you must know everybody from that time
yeah when I started at The Comedy Store
I became a regular at 98 98 a thing or
97 or night
ladies there was no 98 I forgot 99 but
um but when I first started it was like
I started meeting like a lot of Latin
comedians and I met him and I met a lot
of people like I would go to the comedy
club after about boy there was an improv
at the same time
yeah those are improv but there was want
to hear about boy the comedy cabaret
oh here you're here yeah the catacomb
yeah and I'm like I'm gonna love enough
to know there so if I'm Anne Frank
Lozano and he talked about him yeah oh
there's no attempt to admit him you know
we're eating Chinese food and being the
other comedian were about we got up and
dinner's gonna tip Oh for what we're we
ate change the stereotype so you all get
the dollar do you know what Frank did
for before he was a comedian the lab
right in a lab but before that he was
one of the he was I think he was in the
Army or the Marines and he used to jump
out of airplanes paratrooper paratrooper
that's what he was
isn't it amazing dude he looks like a do
that you don't want to mess with no man
but he's the sweetest man you'll ever
meet
I've seen Frank get mad twice and you
can't not laugh cuz it's so out of
character for him like seen him throw
somebody out of the comedy store but
he's the sweetest man ever ever yeah so
you want you you do your paranormal
stuff in your act I do my paranormal
stuff in my act I talk a lot about
ghosts I work in a lot of paranormal
conventions i read tarot cards all day
that's what I do during the day so I got
ya you ever a new economy of wanna be a
rail shout-out to him Houston finance
and you know a lot of community we
travel in the road and we drive a lot
some people listen to Howard or you
don't have because they
the paranormal show our pal all right
yeah dude
he told me man and they had that are
similar so like then that was only on
for 30 minutes and a Spanish show it was
called not just a Kukui and a lot of
Mexican people and I liked it a lot
Spanish listeners will call into the
station and they're like a paranormal
guy and man these people thought goes in
the [ __ ] desert bro like travelling
through coming through the Mexico oh
yeah I saw ghost in the river you know
swimming bro how many people died there
too well you know who well the desert is
just kind of a open yeah there's a lot
of energy there but the you know who had
the very first paranormal show was Bob
Crane from Hogan's Heroes
he was the first radio paranormal who's
all into UFOs and stuff yeah and he was
the first but yeah there's some art Bell
was the master in fact there's a grief
that's the way right yeah he just passed
away there's a great YouTube that you
can listen to of one of his great
episodes where a guy was screaming and
crying and he was like I just got out of
area 51 and aha and in this and all of a
sudden and everything shuts down his
satellite got knocked off the air like
this guy was gone like it wasn't just
the phone hung up it was like the
satellite the whole station went down
and then it came back up and it's like
one of the greatest conspiracy it
listening to and then the guy calls back
and he goes hey it was a hoax but it's
like was it a hoax
no they are about to are only focused on
paranormal or UFOs - well paranormal
UFOs
you know everything kind of conspiracies
- goes to everything everything see when
I was a little boy you know I looked at
the window and I started like a play Wow
no I know it's a plane but back there
didn't over the plane it was like uh I
just started like you know cuz I saw
Star Wars oh yeah but it was like 10
years later and I saw it was cloudy but
I saw the lights and it just flew by
having a bunch of lights like I'm a
little Falcon thing but it was not shave
it with a default I didn't see the
shapes I just saw the lights and it just
took off and then I saw another one pass
by
told my dad of course my dad has an old
theory he said we'd do a little kid he
saw one crash and the ocean a UFO
yeah and then he said that nobody saw
about him other people from now your
name yeah oh yeah and they were told my
dad that he said that no no it was you
know that this is in English in Spanish
no it's just a chingar no your ear up he
goes he goes nah man these [ __ ]
are firing up there I don't know the
[ __ ] you chasing that [ __ ] he's
running he's trying to run down there
right a theory about my dad but recently
like almost in the last year I have a
dream and I keep having this is a crazy
dream Carrie but I have a dream that I'm
in New York and and I don't fly a lot
but I'm not afraid of flying I fly out
every week but I'm afraid of fly in my
dream because it not it's not it's not
we're not flying in a plane no more I'm
getting inside a cap so like it's all
it's not like I'm boarding Space
Mountain now it's just fluorescent
there's a bunch of lines people go in
different directions and I get in this
ship this airplane with four people
first class and they push us they slide
those into the into the plane with a
bunch of other people and then we just
fly real fast and they were home already
but but other times I had dreams where
I'm on earth I'm on a tanker like her
we're on top of the plane we're on top
of the tank with a plane's take off but
there's oh [ __ ] everywhere dude all
around me and I could destroy a
destroyer yeah and then when I'm back
home I could see up in the sky in a day
time and I see like her like a plane
passed by real fast and another one and
they're like this big fighting this guy
in the daytime well you might you might
have some UFO attachment there some UFO
activity going on for real but they were
without there that one time I know the
kid I saw that but but lately I've been
dreaming
days where I'm really afraid of fly back
home because I don't I don't like flying
that way because it's not really a plane
no more if like in a capsule
you know those um when you those old
buildings where you should ever lose
uh-huh yeah like it yes thank you I'm
being vacuumed back to Ally
nobody that could be some UFO stuff
going on everybody has they talk about
angels and demons and UFOs we have our
own little New York you can make a
capsule and it's just like flies by like
you just you see the lights and
everything in the you just just shoot
through the sky like an arrow but you
want to be well you want to be flying
alone in your dreams not in the capsule
that's good that's like it that has the
same effect there's organism on your
body freeze you I am in the capsule
there yeah you gotta go to the capsule
holding you back our marriage no I met
that guy fire in the sky you know the
guy fire in the sky where the you the
loggers where the guy with the one guy
got picked up by the UFO and got thrown
yeah I heard him lecture and is pretty
freaky what's he saying yeah he was in
that you got to see the movie he went
through the whole thing he was awake in
the capsule he was abducted they dropped
him off they kind of healed
yeah well they got he the thing picked
him up and threw him about thirty feet
he must have broken like every bone in
his body but when they returned him a
week later everything was completely
healed except for one hole in his arm
like they they fixed him from from his
arm or something it's crazy but it's a
whole long story you know anything about
DB Cooper yeah yeah about the plane you
know that's a good episode I should do
that I think they actually last year
they had some things that they thought
they found the plane really yeah but I
don't know that it was confirmed but
that was about that thing where people
say that they actually money that they
found the money they may have found it
weren't a little bit worn out a little
bit some fishers
we have a friend a comedian uh Larry
bubbles Brown oh yeah fun legend DB
Cooper I just did a whole episode on
flight 370 Malaysia flight 370 and I
don't think that pilots dead I do I
research that for weeks no no and he
made sure they didn't fly that plane he
did well he definitely took the plane
the way he drove the plane they he was
trying to it would be he was supposed to
go like one flight like this like right
from where he was to Beijing like
Malaysia to Beijing boom but it would be
like if you took your plane and you were
supposed to go San Diego to Baltimore
about Kansas City he turns around and he
starts going like this and then he takes
her right up like going up towards
Alaska that was his flight pattern he
was actually trying to avoid the air
traffic towers but he didn't know that
there's a locator in the the Jets in the
was it called the engine but he was
trying to make that plane disappear
there was about 20 guys on that plane
from a computer company that when all
like I think this guy rotschild paid him
to lose that plane because the way it
landed on the water I know
Rothschild yeah when he he didn't crash
the plane he landed the plane and they
can tell that by the two pieces of
debris he hit the right wing when he was
trying to land it so two pieces broke
off so they know the plane was still
being manned he wanted that plane to
land and sink and never to be found
that's why it happened like that so it
was it is pretty creepy the whole thing
because these 20 I think there was two
guys from Iran on the plane that had
fake passports there was supposed to be
an extra passenger that nobody knew
about but my theory is that when that
computer company 20 guys from that
computer company all died and
disappeared the patent from something
that a big computer chip went to this
raw child like he would make millions
from it now cuz as long as all they were
gone he makes all the money so I think
he landed the plane and the pilot got
out and left because he was right under
radar he's making sure he was under
radar and missing towers it's a pretty
long episode there's pretty detailed
about it was pretty crazy it's crazy
thing
they'll never find that plane what
happens lose that it's called Malaysian
370 I'm paranormal Karen you know in the
heel and remember number I don't know
but I only have like fifteen or thirty
he landed in the ocean he landed I mean
the murky deep where it's gonna go so
far down where they can't even go down
there knew exactly where he was gone
your ears will bust out everything
you'll die you can't there was a flight
simulator in his apartment which means
he had practiced that flight over and
over and over which is that's like yeah
that's like a comic having a room in the
back with empty chairs practicing you
don't you don't have that Sully on the
case right right so he did that but also
he they think because they had a little
bit of interaction just a little bit
they think that he got the other pilot
out of the cockpit and then
depressurized the cabin so everyone
passed out went to sleep died then he
had the plane to himself and he'd just
gone wherever he wanted let's get back
to the Patton was over this Patton
it was just a computer Pat and I'm not
sure what kind of chip it was for or
something but it was kind of important
and this company like almost all their
top engineers were on that particular
plane like 20 of them all gone
disappeared it's have one quick question
I mean wouldn't a company like to have a
private jet you know what I don't know
why they were all on that or the other
question is why were they all together
right but they were they might not have
a private jet they might do yeah so you
brought your tarot cards here I did you
under eating I see that the back of
those cards are like the back of the
cards that's like normal for a la deck
of cards even a Spanish card yeah it's
shaped like that there those cards does
it that's a Spanish card game right that
they look a lot like these cards yeah so
yeah yeah yeah
so well let's do let's see if we can get
specific do you know are against that
there's there's different ways to read
the tarot card right yep there's one
with a diamond right yep cross you know
what you're doing I just wore the cups
and the swords oh yeah well I have a
friend named Lynn Lynn
Lyndon Johnson the guy I met at the
wanted to work at whacking her security
guard he was from I guess Florida he
came on here to be a drummer but that
fool went to he took me to the Bodhi
tree I don't know if they open their
armed arrows like I know it closed one
so I think it really blocks to three
blocks north or east or west of the
Emerald improv and man they have every
paranormal book you can find their nude
witchcraft on every story the kind T of
candles all manifestos a little Chipotle
Rimac where my powers chilled by that
crystal I said Baba be there tomorrow
okay
I don't know the health wanna read
health yeah okay health and future let's
look at Helen relationships
no relationships
we're gonna do my cup of tea be thinking
of Lisa the whole time okay I'm gonna do
help Andy health for you and then we'll
do a general layout I'm sorry about the
noise or but I know that sounds I want
to have pax on Instagram that every time
you shuffle the deck like that
you shall further in a way there knowing
now that they were shuffled on before
that's the way they come out oh you know
I always think it's like every audience
is there's no two audience is the same
do you know what I mean I true never
there can't be even even even if you do
the same act the reaction is always
different it's always different
that's why you can't really I'm pretty
sure people will do the same act over
and over look at this they must feel the
same way why didn't you like me this
time like Craig Schumacher his act is
the same from beginning to end he must
feel like oh that's that's like acting
yeah I do let that bad
feeling self-conscious oh [ __ ] that what
you the joke okay so listen are you
worried about your health or a
particular situation because something
showed up and here's what is going on is
your overall foundation of health is
good okay so you got to do some
maintenance or something changing here
though because under swimming yeah good
because you got some information here
well the Queen's here no King yes
well that's your feminine side taking
care of you okay sort of have you
whatever this situation is anybody's
gonna see that two things about that
card which is if you could do well
acupuncture would be good for you if you
haven't tried that yet its dabbed there
you go lesser lesser expensive form so I
want to tell you something out with
situation I don't mean this in a bad way
the situation is it rock-bottom so in
other words it's working that you're
working up now you're not working down
so you're where it's going to hit rock
bottom you're gonna get some information
that you have to take seriously and
you're gonna have to let go of some
stuff and there's something that you're
walking away from all together because
you're fixing this problem before it
gets bigger okay your foundation is good
but this whatever this changes you're
literally changing your energy and your
DNA like I know they say you can't but
you're changing so much internally at
the same time that be careful of
accidents like tripping and falling and
stuff like that but this is just a
situation you have to work from and you
have to let something go okay they're
not funny but he's gonna walk away from
it and here's the other thing you're not
gonna walk away from it like if I was to
say you had a drug problem like you had
a hit rock bottom that's not what I'm
talking about I'm talking about you're
gonna walk away from it this card is
actually called success abandoned so you
haven't you know you haven't hit a rock
bottom with it you're like I can walk
away from this from here and you're
gonna walk away from it and it's a good
thing it's actually kind of a brave
thing because all this stuff is a big
changes are coming it's kind of scary
but it's going to change everything
okay is everybody scared all right and
you said I wanted to do a general yeah
or career or me see what I was reading
the cards when I was reading the cards
like I will put the cards like the way
she put it but in a different way or
different way but I will hold the card
and just say there's a friend there and
I hold a card but then I would have to
look it up first and go and tell them
what it means they're gonna know what it
means but I told them like over really
basic way the face but I'm a little bit
of a historian on the cowboy hat bro you
folder alright okay
same card pop up - same three same cards
okay all right so I'm gonna explain look
that here yeah in two ways so and I'm
gonna say sort of like is in two general
energetic things going on here first of
all your cards pass and manifesting what
you want like I think you're you've done
something really good here to where
you've reached one of your points of
success or like I got it all now right
now and that's good you are gonna deal
with this health problem though or
whatever it is and really pay attention
did you hear that
I did I did - yeah yeah somebody's
trying to tell you something okay you
have to slow down for a little bit okay
if you can take a vacation or something
and this is not an exciting I can't wait
to go to Italy this is like we need to
sit and be quiet for a while and you
need to regroup because you're getting
ready to start the second like whatever
that amped up like you were like yeah
I'm gonna have everything in here I go
that worked
now you got to sit and regroup cuz also
what you think you want right now is not
exactly what its gonna be in a little
bit but here's the thing after you sit
or settle in and this is a phrase I want
to use be okay with yourself like I'm
okay right now I'm gonna quiet that was
the thing like about that dream all of
this
and help is gonna arrive you're gonna
feel like wow I heard three times
somebody said when are you gonna do this
or when you get into that and you're
like I wasn't even thinking of that and
then all of a sudden you're gonna be
like that's it and it's like once again
you're gonna be like boom I call this
the Charlie Sheen card because that's
how you get from A to B without any you
get there fast you don't care who you
not go yeah I'm getting there so you
have a whole second this year one for
you is all about regrouping and putting
that forward moving man move and move
and moving so that's your general so
rest rest you want to do you want to
rest up now because they're do you you
said you have one kid you have two kids
three okay two showed up for some reason
is one much older like a penis okay okay
yeah there's a split between the two the
two younger ones I feel like there's a
really good phase coming there with them
or there's families back that's what I
want to say family's back so take that
all in but really like seriously with
that this one is again about letting go
regrouping letting go these two cards
are almost about meditation okay but you
have like in the next couple years
you're not even gonna your life's gonna
look so different I can't even tell you
but like I said this is like the what is
it that you're in the eye of the storm
and you're getting ready to go into the
second one so enjoy quiet enjoy quiet
the next phase is coming yeah man yeah
all right it's a true because uh what do
they look the same do the two younger
ones okay identical dog the kids
Rodrigo right yes ma'am hey darling what
would you like me to read for you
whatever you think you whatever you
would recommend I will do in general for
you and then you can throw me into a
category categories way more specific
than a general but what general is good
to start with seems that at least feel
like the general read is the one people
can make fun of because you're good to
anyone but then I go yeah okay dude what
are you waiting for
oh my god all right so yes so there's
something about a lot of I want to
either say anxiety or worried and or no
sleep or something that's getting
there's a lot of resistance and you
waiting and I kind of want to say this
is a weird thing I want to say your
career has already started so you need
to think of it from that point okay
you're already whatever you're doing or
whatever you're trying to do it's ahead
of your thinking okay you're already
there think of it this way you get the
fool card which is one of the best cards
in the day it's all about new beginnings
and taking risks okay it's time to start
taking some risks and here is the other
thing this is the writers card okay if
you have been holding back on something
an idea or or whatever you're writing it
this is really what you got to go to
okay you're gonna start that you're
gonna walk away there's some sort of a
shift coming for you there may be a
person
I don't ever predict death but there's
something that I feel like is it's not
your fiancee but there's something here
where there are some pain coming up okay
and this is - I kind of feel like it's
with family it's bigger it's not mom or
dad but there may be somebody that gets
ill or something that's going to club
that happen a couple years ago okay then
what that could be is you haven't let go
of the pain yet - no okay and is that
part of what you're writing because it
kind of looks like the two are connected
or one
is tapping off the other for some reason
okay once you get past that it's good
you're you're over and then also
something about a house okay so if you
if your dream or something is about a
house that's coming or there's a house
or there's a movie oh that's what it is
okay but it's not done yet
right not completely okay it's almost
done you okay I'm good we stopped no ok
[Laughter]
know that about you yeah so that's your
general so if you want to give me a
space
[Laughter]
you my friend yes okay here we go
the winner would advise everybody here
they got a light on fire dollar thirty
two three ticket thing Karen you mostly
stick to like corporate comedy and
that's where the bulk of your work is
like yeah conventions and stuff like you
know what now I it's real different now
um yeah and I try to I try to I do
whatever I'm not I'm very funny though
thanks thank you her said it's very
funny and she's not really yeah you are
very psychic yourself and if that is not
turn if you don't feel like that's on
coming through too much it's absolutely
going to start coming through over here
thank you
yeah she knows what you're doing
[Laughter]
so two cards from the pass again I have
you a little bit like him not quite as
much like what are you waiting for but
sort of something you're waiting for
something to grow and you're kind of
like you're being do you think do you do
a comedy
no I but I manage him and I we're
developing something okay okay oh that's
okay that's good but you're being very
very reasonable about it very reasonable
about it and I almost want to say that's
what your hold like that kind of this is
why I say you're psychic you know when
to hold and when to let go okay because
right now it's in holding and I know we
want to go hey just hang on
again I'm gonna point out this card of
there is something that watch out for I
don't have at you or you because you
guys come up together somebody watch out
for a trip and fall or something like
like take it slow it's not a bad one
it's about your done is it your back
okay then then that might be where it
gets fixed or something like that
because what you're selling here or
whatever you're packaging it's almost
insane and linked with his which is the
time is coming when if you're like this
isn't moving we can't get it right this
and that there's gonna be a time where
you're like well now 50 people want it
now everybody wants it so you're gonna
have you're gonna making some really
smart decisions but I think there's a
male that is going to come in that is um
I don't know that you two are gonna get
along like this but the male has good
information and you'll respect each
other and he's gonna help this come
along okay it could be but it this is a
person that's not and I don't know this
person but this person is not poor so
this person would already be there
already have his own money or something
like that and he's gonna do daddy sugar
daddy but listen you start to trust your
instincts like I almost want you to work
on it okay because you're gonna be the
diplomat between you and this guy and
all of you and somebody else and it's
gonna be a very important role and your
skills are gonna be more natural than
you've ever seen them before
so but this is song like we're gonna get
a TV show you didn't do you didn't do
any acting or entertaining okay I used
to be in a band and I was in theater Oh
College okay I actually think there's a
time you're gonna revisit that I know
you say you're done but I don't think
you're done I don't think you should be
yeah yeah absolutely
all right where to now kids that it is
everybody freaked out yeah let's do that
yeah no pressure there might walk out
yeah I'll be gentle and honest what's up
fool
you have any shows coming up people come
to you actually this weekend I'll be in
a stir-crazy in Phoenix or Glendale
Arizona there and then what's the month
after this August yeah
August oddly enough I'm performing a
wedding all right so you guys just saw
you on Instagram Oh Ron Taos key at Ron
Taos key and if they go paranormal Karen
if you look that up anywhere you'll get
the podcast the webseries my my page and
and all that stuff so did you guys have
a fight today like a battle something
there's something looming that's not
coming it's done it's like a it's like a
big it's a big to-do okay
there's so many
[Laughter]
well I got one in particular it's
actually gonna balance back out but
there's too much emotion and I know that
sounds crazy because you're married but
there's too much emotion it's gonna
start I'm not worried about you guys at
all if that's what I'm sure you weren't
or you wouldn't have asked me on the
podcast but once you get past this I'm
gonna explain to you this way July and
August all bets are off everything is
gonna be I can swear right everything's
gonna be [ __ ] up okay expect
whatever July to August it's gonna be
crazy and I'm kind of seeing that an
emotional thing here but there's a point
here where you walk away from whatever
I'm talking about and that is the
healthiest thing and you return to the
place where you guys are happy and also
the place where you're happy it has a
lot to do with your creativity so don't
separate that do you know what I mean
like don't say well that's where she
does the job and then we're married it's
like you guys creating together is the
magic yeah that's not a big issue in our
lives is balancing the work and the
personal relationship because it's all
we think and eat and breathe yes
everything right I don't know if that's
a bad thing though because that's how
you communicate creativity is tied to it
is is tied to your happiness
so yeah you you guys don't need to go to
a meditation center and watch birds you
know that's not gonna
you be like who are you I don't even
know you anymore well you are very much
tied creatively that's why your fire I
don't know if your fire signs but it's a
fire connection oh your water signs over
there Gemini so he's an heir oh that
that yeah it's pretty good though are
you guys know Aquarius is not I think
it's an air so you don't put air air air
a lot of ideas a lot of talking this is
gonna this is gonna balance out but this
is just gonna be a little roller coaster
I'm just gonna give you the July and
August just [ __ ] it it's all over the
place thank you that's going on in your
head now that's big changes
[Laughter]
so anybody else 2019 for Trump to go
that's I think so what's all for the
questions and what and what else do you
do like besides you go go go sardine I
know I do I I go out and I go ghost
hunting and I I tell people to not be
afraid of ghosts they're just energy you
know really yeah they are energy yeah
they turn TVs and on and off all the
time for eels yeah can you communicate
yes well mediums are more about talk to
the dead and talk to spirits but I can
somewhat communicate with them but
people can regular people oh yeah
absolutely and you can get a lot of
evidence that if I took you ghost
hunting and I showed you what a EVP was
you would be very amazed electronic
voice phenomena good animals he goes
yeah my best friend's an animal
communicator and we find lost animals a
rabbit leg stomping but there's nothing
there right yeah yeah yeah there see
something there in fact him go in
investigating we use a camera that's
designed kind of like the eye of a cat
because they have so much more on the
spectrum on the light spectrum so they
see more moving around and stuff like
that so yeah yeah my friend's animal
communicator and she'll call me and go
I'll look at the dog won't be eating and
she'll go courage says that you put new
food in there and he's not eating the
square food and he wants the triangle
food back and there'll be exactly what
has happened oh yeah oh yeah Brian's
Calero another comic he told a story
about how you're staying in a comedy
condo one time and the cabinets in the
living room in the kitchen slash living
room kept opening up and whenever he was
sleeping in the bedroom and then he he
had I guess had experiences with ghosts
before he's the most cynical person so I
didn't believe that he I couldn't
believe he believed but he talked about
how he communicated with the ghosts and
said well what if I sleep out here in
the living room but it would that be
okay you know let me know and then then
none of the cabinets opened up anymore
oh yeah they didn't want him in the
bedroom I heard a story once of this
couple moved in this house every morning
that cabinets would be open the same
thing cabinets open so they asked the
the these people had lived there forever
before them so they asked their kids who
they had bought the house from after
they passed away why that happened and
what heaven was when they first bought
that house like in the 20s she did not
want cabinets she wanted open shelves
and he put in cabinets one day so every
day he would get up she would get up and
she would open the cabinets like I hate
these which is exactly why I'll never
get married because that anger carries
on yeah there's a couple buried in a
graveyard in I think it's Argentina and
they had a fight when they were like
thirty thirty years or something and
they never spoke to each other again
they died like in their 70s age their
graves are back to back like they're
still not talking to each other in the
afterlife
that's a grudge man in Mexico there's a
ghost and I was based on kind of like
it's similar to another team is another
goes in Ireland but this girl she was my
in against and she fell in love with a
Spaniard and there was a pose and then
like she would he promised her do and I
get married I don't know about you Spain
so then she got pregnant and he didn't
wanna hurt anymore you know I guess he
had half babies so she's okay she killed
them and then she thought that she'll
take her now right but he never did he
never came back so there's a ghost of
her roaming Mexico going where's my
children
oh yeah oldest army SEOs la Llorona and
it's just crying oh yeah well you know
walk around her gown famous right yeah
that's a that's a pretty intense that's
oh that's a ghost that's definitely
afraid to cross over if you killed
somebody yeah we've had we were up at a
place right up in Santa Paula and there
was some river blue yeah there was
something awful this place called Glen
tavern and there's a couple of rooms
that are pretty awful and in one of them
is the ghost of a spirit he died he had
drug overdose
and we said how come you don't want to
cross over and he said there's people
like killed on the other side and he's
afraid to see them again so it's like
being a you know those spirits are like
I spirits so it's it's the same they
think the same we do if they're boring
in life they're boring in death I don't
need to speak to all of them do you know
anything about the comedy stories goes
yeah well the comedy stories got a lot
more going on than just ghosts yeah
because they had on construction yeah
yeah they have negativity upon
negativity they you know so a human
spirit can only probably move like two
pounds like maybe turn on and off a
light or do something like that but they
have stuff there that's putting chairs
on top of stuff and so they have a lot
more than just a human spirit they have
probably a lot of things fighting in
there Wow yeah it's pretty creepy a lot
of strong personalities yeah to kill
gangsters before most of us before the
comedy story there's two point yeah I
just did I worked in that Harvey's in
Portland and did a whole episode on
their tunnels underneath the city oh I
went to the Harvey's through the kitchen
and they open that and there is a
there's a door that's blocked and now
the other tonally to lead up to
Chinatown yeah yeah they yeah that's one
Chinese people walking around in public
so they have to go through tunnels
oh no well that's a Shanghai they used
to Shanghai people through there and we
went down and I was gonna do like a
comedy bit where they dragged me like it
looks like I'm being dragged like I'm
being shanghaied and when I got down
there it was so creepy I was like not
here now I hear we're not waking up
anything down here but I did a half an
hour interview with the guy downstairs
in the tunnels where I'm walking around
them talking about the tunnels and then
we get it back to LA and you check when
you listen to those you can get EVPs
which are literally voices that are
imprinted that we can't hear that are
imprinted on the tape and like he goes
well Portland has a really strange
history and in the back you can hear
somebody scream
and so I said to my friend can you go
through the tapes for me he goes through
the tapes and his name is Dave before I
even know I'm in the tunnel taping this
I get home I go I don't have time Dave
can you do it for me the end of the tape
there's a guy that goes hi Dave that's
none of us so like that thing knew
before I did that I was going to give
that tape to somebody else that's not
that's greater than something greater
than human spirit yeah something awful
yeah is that creepy enough for everybody
did I scare others bro you can see why I
don't have a lot of second what are some
of your favorites I know you talked
about you could talked about other
phenomenon phenomena and phenomena and
stuff but what what are some of your
favorite stories I heard my favorite
creepy stories around the the world oh
Portland was one of my favorites
unbelievably one of my favorites I'm
trying to think as I've been so many
places there's a place called Virginia
City up in Reno Nevada that is just
horrible was like people getting in bed
with you like strange spirits getting
into bed with you and stuff like that I
think my teas my favorite story that's
hard to that's hard to pick you mean
creepiest story or the creepiest women
you are always
there's something that can happen in
real life but it happens a lot what
happens sometimes when you investigate
paranormal is a thing called a walk-on
where another spirit walks into someone
else's body and you're literally talking
to a different person and it can happen
where like like if she all the sudden in
turn had a Scottish accent and was
screaming at you and it's it's a real
thing when you aggravate it happened the
first time on the Star of India and San
Diego there was - something was going on
in the cellar and it was too loud and we
knew we were aggravating these spirits
and we come upstairs and sure enough the
guy goes scratch me behind my neck
which is that's an entrance point if
something's trying to get in and
something got in him and it just wasn't
him anymore and we had to like get him
off the ship and get
it out but that's the scariest thing
I've ever seen not a possession where
it's a horrible you know all it's like
another human being in the body with
someone else and it's it's like all I
could think was we can't have the death
penalty because that's it was real it
was really someone else in there
that's pretty freaky extras this mm-hmm
happen to a little boy actually not the
little girl so but it's a true story
I've been American right I believe it
did I can't remember that part it was
art bell always used to interview the
priest that was that the movie was based
on Father Malachi Martin and yeah but
there's a lot of do you think possession
and exorcism those stories were more
when people didn't understand mental
illness and you know fifty fifty one
hand washes the other there's a lot of
calls I get for people that are just
basically schizophrenic and they don't
realize it because it doesn't show up
usually until people like in their 20s
so they're like my life was fine and now
something's talking to me and I don't
understand but a lot of the way I see it
when your energy or your aura is
compromised then you can get things
attached to things can attack you things
can steal your energy if you stay kind
of within yourself and you couldn't you
keep your energy safe you'd be fine but
you can you know a lot of times when
you're drunk your energy is compromised
that's why a lot of blackout drunks do
things you go the person never would do
that in their real life I would never
bet that guy's you're off yeah so it's
kind of like that so yeah so you got to
watch you got to take care of yourself
your spirits ever die I know they I
think energy just transforms and what's
up with the devil that's not that what
the [ __ ] doc make your [ __ ] that would
bring me up that there's there's devil
there's a devil there's demons it's sort
of that's a long answer that's the look
there is one yet yes there is there are
there are negative things out there and
they actually have system and and but
there's it's like this there's human
spirit and there's devil or demon
there's a million things between here
there's elementals there's human spirits
there's faeries there's all
and stuff in there so Nostradamus true
or con-artists total time no that wasn't
that wasn't a 7f Leary's books and so
was the bermuda try they figured out the
bermuda triangle there is something
about a gas that the earth admits that
comes up there that it messes up with
the airplanes and stuff and and it
probably does have a de menthe
interdimensional quality but it has that
also there's a lot of you know how
people buy crystals there's a lot of
crystals on in the ocean there they
think that's where atlantis was so it's
already causing a gravitational kind of
thing I wouldn't play the crafter that I
don't know a lot a lot but a lot of
ships yeah yeah a lot of crazy stuff
there yeah the the Mothman is still my
favorite with him oh my god mom is the
greatest the Mothman prophecy with it
yeah yeah it's but he's making
appearances now mostly in Chicago like
the moth man's back which one yeah yeah
like a flying big wings and a guy and
red eyes and yeah very very interesting
not really aggressive towards people but
terrifying and kind of they always said
he was like a omen he's a omen but the
real Mothman story that went on in Point
Pleasant West Virginia is crazy crazy he
was there at the same time people don't
realize there were men in black showing
up there were UFOs everywhere was like
that with that place turned into this
little vortex of craziness and there
were just more more things going on
there than anywhere anyone at one time
and it didn't even make any sense like
why was there a UFO and then there's
this the just crazy they have a Mothman
festival every year and I'm waiting for
them to invite me who David Icke not
ringing the bell David Icke he believes
in oh yeah yeah yeah he's right yeah
he's right cuz I don't know like we're
now you know Jim Morrison he's from our
lair right and he had this song I am The
Lizard King I could do anything but when
they did
of places unknown or what the - the lost
worlds in Los Angeles and the guy he did
like a story he said they actually was
people before time that they were
actually even la who were half lives
were half man that's yeah I mean you're
gonna keep them all out and they went
underground and in the living of sewers
of our late but I live like a long time
ago but there are that's what they say
about the tunnels of LA that say that
reptilians live down there now I didn't
even know we had tunnels yeah yeah
tunnels and gypsies we got gypsies down
there too so but there's a lot there's a
lot more going on here than but la is
pretty much haunted flat anytime you
have gold or in California Gold Rush
thing you know like that kind of thing
but LA personalities we're all big
personalities in LA we're all you know
people don't just pass here it's all
very connected somebody just had me do a
Vista Gatien in her house and I was like
yeah there's so much going on here it's
ridiculous yeah none of it was dangerous
but it was like yeah I know why stuff is
moving around and stuff like that how do
you know are you just feeling this stuff
when you get to when you do that actual
type of work when you get to their house
yeah a lot of its felt a lot of it is
when I was working with a medium and we
would we would kind of make our own
assessments and then match them and a
lot of it was really the energy of the
place was just you could feel a
difference from room to room like oh
this room is horrible this one's fine
yeah yeah you're and you're way more in
touch than you give yourself credit well
we had an apartment that was like a
railroad apartment where it was like all
the rooms were on one side off of a
hallway and we would shut off the living
room in the winter because there was
horrible the windows in the insulation
or whatever the ceiling was bad the
ceiling of each of the windows so we'd
shut off that door and we wouldn't use
it in the winter and I went in there for
something and I swear I felt somebody
like on my back like like right like
watching what I was doing and following
me and the but in that room and I got
out really fast it's so strange it's
like our first room in the house and
that's a weird feng shui that
so that's a weird energy moving through
you want it you want it to keep you you
want to keep your house upbeat you want
innocent you know incense and positivity
and yeah you don't want to make it a
mess yeah craziness well thank you have
you back crazy [ __ ] out here
brother of crazy bro she knew you dawg
the first car is about Lisa yeah
the Hermit issue
are you her me she's very for Rodriguez
Rodrigo I'm sorry don't be disappointed
it you're already there that one shows a
gift from God that you're not seeing
yeah it's not the guy with the story was
it oh and you worried about what's not
gonna happen
you know I have a dream about 90 every
once in a while that um I'm in the back
seat of a moving vehicle in and I can't
drive it but it's driving itself and I'm
gonna phrase gonna crash but never
crashes no control that no control in
your life yeah so now when I was doing
loud drugs was so fool teeny meaning
maybe you got a jingle right here man
was tricky stuff with cool man
well go eat some tarot cards yeah Lisa
over here Hermit Karen rodowsky thank
you very much thank you but we don't
know what so fool podcast
thank you now I'm gonna go check out
your podcast actually freak me out shout
out to the late art Bell
the best Frank Manzano yeah man
there's another popular listen to that
that nothing to do with it but it's all
science fiction it's pretty trippy tomb
at night on bail night bill welcome to
night Vale I gotta get that anything
scary what uh thanks guys